i'm in cape may at the southern tip of
new jersey where the u.s army corps of
engineers have just finished rebuilding
this beach
a dredge is going offshore and it's like
a vacuum that is sucking a sand and
water mix up into the dredge
then it travels back towards the shore
pumps that sand and water mix onto the
beach
and then bulldozers and construction
equipment will shape that beach and
build that template
that's designed to reduce the damages
from storms we're using multiple hopper
dredges and miles of pipe
we're using construction equipment
bulldozers excavators
all to complete this job we are
demobilizing from the site so all this
equipment is going to another section in
cape may
and we'll begin dredging in beechville
operations at that location
miami beach in america the gold coast in
australia
the beaches of dubai around the world
engineers
dredge sand from offshore and pump it
back
onto beaches not only because the
tourists demand it
but more importantly because those
beaches protect the folks
living next door from the ocean and as
sea levels rise
beach erosion is happening faster and
faster well in new jersey there's lots
of infrastructure that's at risk from
storms that's
boardwalks utilities roads homes
businesses
and so this process is the best means we
have to reduce storm damages in a cost
effective
and an environmentally acceptable way
but there are other uses for sand too
every concrete building in the world
every skyscraper is basically just
a load of sand like this stuck together
with cement and the world is running out
of it i know that sounds strange but the
construction industry
uses billions of tons of sand every year
so the obvious answer would seem to be
use sand from elsewhere right we've got
whole deserts and ocean floors full of
the stuff
but those sands aren't useful desert and
sea sands are too
fine too smooth they don't stick
together properly
either for making concrete or for
rebuilding a beach like this
it has to be this kind of sand sand
that's been created by moving water and
waves over eons
this is not a renewable resource not on
any human time scale
and if it's not there to protect the
coast then the folks who live nearby
should start getting worried
this project was first completed in 1990
and we've come back
numerous times over the years to
re-nurse and pump additional sand onto
the beach
if we didn't pump the sand into this
area and build an engineered system
the communities would be at a higher
risk of of damages from
hurricanes nor'easters and other storm
events
now running out of sand doesn't mean
that we're suddenly going to be unable
to build anything it just means that
as supply goes down the price of
construction will go up
and there are going to be some rough
market forces no one's considering strip
mining the jersey shore anytime soon but
journalist vince baizer spent years
investigating illegal sand mining
in the developing world and brought back
reports of disappearing islands and
devastated ecosystems and murderous
black market
sand mafias hundreds of people have been
killed
over sand now here the corps of
engineers are keeping a community safe
some birds safe and making sure there'll
still be a beach here
for tourists this summer but who knows
in a hundred years
maybe new jersey will get a better offer
for this sand
you